first question the second round Julian
Herrera ABC 7 News Bay Area this is
questions is for you Kauai to be back
here for the first to be back here for
the first time on such a big stage since
your injury especially the finals
especially after what it's taken to get
back here how does it feel to get a win
in Oracle tonight I don't think about
what happened two years ago pretty much
living in and now and I'm just happy we
were able to get a game three win
another step closer to our goal let it
rip just the right message tonight for
you guys on the white board and who
wrote it and how well did Kyle Lowry
follow that advice I think we all kind
of follow that advice but it is easier
to look at that now and say it worked
great for us you know especially a great
shooting night but you know it's been a
while since the whole playoff series we
haven't really had a good team shooting
night I knew eventually at some point we
were due for one so luckily we got you
know once a night but we still have to
do a better job defensively Atlanta to
Florida limit those guys are better so
we don't have to rely on our offense or
our shooting to win games for us but you
know luckily it did tonight
and hopefully next game we can continue
to stay warm and let it rip and
hopefully play even better defense over
here Danny over here Shaquille O'Neal
apparently offered some shooting advice
to you he's a pure shooter I don't know
if you guys knew that yeah okay can you
fill us in on what he suggested and what
effect it had on your performance
tonight yeah I spoke to him before the
game briefly um you know he's always on
the TNT set and he was out there before
the game and every time I see him you
know he's giving me his pure shooting
advice you know because he was he was
good at it and but you know just that
the fundamentals the small things
telling me to be confident and just you
know hold the follow-through and you
know obviously I have
a good shootin night is easy - to see
that his advice has worked but um you
know has he always just yells them you
know leave it and that's his way of
saying you know leave your hand up there
hold your father and be confident you're
shot but you know he's always been that
guy to me everywhere every year we get
on the playoffs or on this stage or you
know he comes over and tells me you know
stay confident and you know give me his
shooting advice standing in the back
right Danny or Kauai
what do you make of all the fan support
so far I don't know if you're aware but
several Raptors fans dozens of Raptors
fans rather stuck around after the game
broke out a rendition of Oh Canada and I
just want to know what your thoughts
were on just all this fans support
people travelling all the way here to
the Bay Area to support you gosh I'll
take this one since he answers probably
a ton of them but our fans have been
amazing for us throughout the whole
season and in the playoffs especially
you know in the first two games you did
a great job we didn't hold our end up to
set game two but you know we had to come
back home hopefully you know keeping
them proud or make them proud and
hopefully up in the series would be
great but all around the world is theirs
you know Canadian fans surprisingly you
know it's one thing I've learned being
on this team a lot of Canada is all over
and it's kind of close people from
Vancouver may drive down but Raptors
fans are crazy man they're all over the
place and they come from all over the
place to make the games to watch the
games to support us and we know how big
of a stage and how big of accomplishment
is just us getting here but we know the
job's not done we want to continue to
make them proud and hopefully you know
give them the first title Michael in the
center towards the back Kawhi Michael
Grange from Sports Net going into the
game especially when you found out the
rap the Warriors are going to be without
clay how important was it in retrospect
to make sure you got this one on the
road it was very important but I really
didn't find out till the no tip-off
started they told us that he was playing
tonight no that was the mindset going
out on the floor that he's playing
and you know it was a lot of pressure
it's a lot of pressure too we know if
you know one of the main guys is not
playing they can still come out and get
a win you know step played great tonight
but um you know it's big I'm happy we
got it two wins away now and let's see
what momentum this momentum carry us to
Robert Arash Dan right Robert little BSO
Kauai when you have such balanced
scoring from your starting unit how does
that help your game both offensively and
defensively and the secondary question
that I had for you know you're not on
social media but I don't know if you
were aware that your catchphrase the
board man gets paid it's been going very
viral of right now we just want to
confirm is that actually something that
you said you just say that back when I
was in high school in college you know
just when they get to this to this
league just about we know working hard
basically I'll work in the opponent you
know rebounds help you win games big
rebounds offensive rebounds limiting the
team in one shot and you know that used
to be our motto I'm just you know some
of us that were in college that was
trying to get to this point
I forgot drove the first two questions
the balanced scoring of the starting
unit helped open up your game
offensively I mean you know once I'm
driving in the paint I'm kicking out two
guys I'm making shots the defense you
know doesn't want to collapse as easy
and you know we just got to keep playing
him in a flow of really I feel like we
just we don't need to worry about me
scoring a basketball we all could score
with the offerings that we have you just
got to keep moving it at times when I do
have the ball that the offense gets real
stagnate and you know we just stay in
one spot not so easy to guard if you're
defending us so it's about just moving
the ball playing at a play no you know
the team sport and trusting everyone
Danny a rash my dad was sports net in
the back here you'd sit before the
finals I'm gonna keep shooting I'm gonna
keep shooting I'm gonna keep shooting
when you when you started feeling it
that last stretch at the end of the
quarter hitting the two threes within 22
seconds on the end of the period hitting
the other one just just how hot were you
feeling at that point oh I wouldn't say
hot but I was comfortable you know we
had a good rhythm we had a good flow we
had got a good couple of stops it's
where we can run and get our transition
where we get some good uncontested looks
got a few good looks and your they fell
for me I still felt like there was a
couple of opportunities that I had
missed and I if I was hot I usually
would have made it I had a couple of
good looks after that and maybe was due
to fatigue but you know guys played hard
guys made shots we we um you know do the
little things and end of the day like he
said the board man is a blue collar blue
collar team these guys did all the
little things we needed to do to get a
win and obviously making shots helps but
rebounding blocking shots Serge was
amazing at running back spring back guys
were amazing rebounding pascal mark they
hit a timely tommy buckets for us and
had some timely stops and rebounds for
us right over here Dan Devine from the
ringer Danny you were talking a lot
about flow earlier Nick was talking
about pace and the importance of that
what what role does Kyle Lowery play in
getting you know getting you into that
flow developing that pace huge all year
that's why I love playing with the guys
so much because he's a big reason why I
get so many looks on him and Pascal of
you know them being him being the
quarterback Pascal being the wrong
receiver and he throwing that ball ahead
and the defense collapse his kick-out
open looks for me and when he's you know
qui obviously penetrating attack in the
basket transition they collapsed there's
some some good looks for us and a half
court set it's a little easy to guard
that and match up but um you know kalos
a huge I guess part of our pace and
that's why he's so as well he gets paid
the big bucks man you know he does a
little things for us even when he's not
scoring and tonight he scored well but
um you know the biggest thing that he
brings for us is that edge you know he's
a he's a bulldog he's a pitbull down
there and he's he's gonna take charges
he's gonna get rebounds and a box of
people out into the dirty work he's a
blue-collar guy and he's gonna give us
pace you know so as much as people like
to you know get on him about and
shooting well not scoring it's not
really his job you know we don't need
him to score as much with the guys we
have here with Kawai pascal fred myself
on the perimeter be able to shoot some
so if he does score it's a plus for us
but um it'd be great to have everybody
to continue to keep scoring make it easy
for us but defensively I said we have to
be back